et avec nous en plateau depuis ce début
ce début d'édition c'est géraldoucan
donc vous êtes le fondateur d'Alpha 7
drone et vous êtes basé à Maurepas vous
proposez des prestations de prise de vue
arrière alors quelles sont justement
toutes ces prestations puisque j'ai
justement votre carte et vous dites
faire de la photogrammétrie de
l'orthophoto qu'est-ce que c'est alors
ça c'est une partie assez technique déjà
dans le drone il y a deux catégories on
a la catégorie ouverte qui est basée
pour le loisir et la catégorie
spécifique qui est plus basée pour les
professionnels donc moi je vais parler
plus de la partie spécifique
professionnelle dont je fais partie donc
la photogrammétrie en fait c'est un
procédé de prise de vue de plusieurs
photos avec un chevauchement compris
entre aller 65 et 80%
et de là le sujet avec un logiciel bien
spécifique on peut le mettre en 3D donc
ça aide les architectes s'ils n'ont pas
la possibilité d'aller sur place de
faire des mesures et de pas polluer le
le chantier qui
d'être sur le chantier de polluer de
ralentir le chantier
et donc finalement vous vous souhaitez
vous diversifier vous n'êtes pas
spécialement spécifique à un domaine
vous pouvez faire justement comme vous
le disiez des prestations pour le grand
public donc ça peut aussi toucher des
mariages par exemple
il y a un côté professionnel
et vous avez d'autres aussi thématiques
pour l'instant je suis en face de
lancement et un peu de prospect de
prospection donc je suis ouvert toute
proposition que ça soit pour faire des
mariages de la prise de vue photos
prochainement je vais faire une
réalisation d'un reportage photo pour un
couvreur en région parisienne et après
pour les agriculteurs lors de dégâts de
d'animaux sauvages de sur leur culture
donc ça va il y a un panel énorme de
prestations à faire et comment ça se
passe justement le démarchage c'est
difficile de trouver des clients ou pour
l'instant c'est très difficile parce
qu'en fait les gens croient que le drone
s'est fait pour les espionner alors que
pas du tout on est là pour assurer la
sécurité on évite au cordiste de monter
à des hauteurs pas possible ou des
particuliers qui risqueraient de monter
de se casser le col du fémur donc on va
essayer d'éviter d'engranger les
urgences pour ça avec ça et non c'est un
gage de temps d'argent et de sécurité
la question en fait c'est qu'est-ce que
vous apportez en plus qu'une personne
qui a déjà en possession d'un drone
qu'est-ce que quelle est la valeur
ajoutée finalement alors pour la partie
spécifique en fait moi je suis certifié
de la formation photographe donc ça je
peux prétendre à faire des suivis de
chantier d'aller prospecter les
professionnels du BTP et tout l'ensemble
des professionnels que ça soit
secours ou
le BTP en général et à la rédaction
également vous a préparé quelques
questions donc pour les téléspectateurs
qui qui souhaiteraient en savoir
davantage sur les normes puisque
utiliser un drone finalement c'est pas
il y a des interdictions il y a des
autorisations alors à quelle altitude
maximale est-ce qu'on peut faire voler
un drone alors là tout dépend de là où
on se trouve mais en règle générale si
on n'a pas de contre-indication c'est
120 m de hauteur
très bien et ce qu'il y a des espaces
qui sont interdits au vol et ce qu'il y
a des endroits particuliers à éviter
alors on a des restrictions que ça soit
tant
drone de loisirs on a des restrictions à
respecter notamment sur un portail
Géoportail pardon et on a la partie
spécifique ou quand on fait des
réalisations on fait des demandes
préfectorales et quand on est à côté
d'une d'un aéroport on est assujetti à
baisser la hauteur pour ne pas
interférer sur les couloirs aériens
est-ce qu'on peut voler à n'importe
quelle heure de la journée
deux jours comme de nuit pour la partie
loisirs toujours elles doivent respecter
les la corne la nuit aéronautique donc
qui se passe une demi-heure avant le
lever du soleil et une demi-heure après
le coucher du soleil
et en partie spécifique donc
professionnelle on doit faire des
déclarations préalables alors je vois
que vous aviez également apporté du
matériel est-ce que vous pouvez nous en
dire un peu plus on a un drone on a un
casque alors ça c'est le don que
j'utilise en prestation ça c'est le
casque que je mets au client parce que
des fois ils veulent sentir la sensation
que ça fait de monter dans les airs de
voir un peu ce que on voit de haut donc
je leur mets le casque et ils en sont
ravis ça c'est la radiocommande que
j'utilise pour pourpiloter le drone
super ben écoutez merci beaucoup Gérald
de Toucan d'être venu en plateau pour
nous faire découvrir justement votre
entreprise et puis on vous souhaite de
trouver plein de clients et merci
également de nous avoir éclairé sur
l'utilisation d'un drone